bonjour bertrand le grand merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur ft france alors
on voit que le nombre de cas augmente
sûrement à cause des nombreux tests
réalisés mais concrètement est-ce qu'il
faut s'inquiéter alors bonjour
en fait je suis on peut s'inquiéter
quand même puisque le le sait pas
seulement le nombre de têtes qui
augmente si l'incidence est donc j'ai la
fréquence de la maladie qui augmente la
difficulté qu'on a c'est que en mars en
or même en février et avant nous n'avons
fait aucune cohorte ici à l'époque nous
avons choisi de tester que les
symptomatique et donc nous n'avons pas
d'échantillons qui nous permettrait une
comparaison entre aujourd'hui et il ya
donc pour répondre clairement
on voit bien que le taux d'incidence
augmente mais on n'est pas capable de
vous comparer et de vous dire si ça
correspond au mois de mars de cette
année ou si on est au mois de novembre
de l'année dernière
c'est très embêtant pour nous pour le
deviner à partir de quand ce taux en
très rares à des cas un peu plus grave
alors on tout l'été on a parlé
d'une fameuse deuxième vague est ce que
potentiellement c'est comme ça qu'elle
peut commencer cette deuxième vague
la deuxième vague c'est peut-être une
formulation un peu journalistique j'irai
je ne sais pas si aujourd'hui nous avons
terminé la première vague
par contre on est sur un court aux
navires us donc c'est une p à 3 mois 6
mois maximum et donc on sait qu'on a de
plusieurs vagues dans la même année et
que on avait des retours avec une
fréquence habituellement que ce culte de
l'unité beaucoup plus forte une fois
tous les trois ans alors de nombreux
tests sont réalisés partout en france
1,1 million c'était l'objectif du
gouvernement parfois dans les grandes
villes
les résultats se font attendre parfois
cinq jours pour avoir des résultats
est-ce que ce délai peut représenter un
problème alors je ne suis pas certain
que soit le résultat qui pose problème
et plus le rendez vous je ne me trompe
pas pour le présent et pour pour
prélever je pense qu'en terme de
machines on est capable de près de
donner un rendu un résultat en 38 heures
par contre chez des rats pour prélever
qui commencent à manquer et pour ça il
ya une solution c'est de demander aux
médecins la mairie et aux internes et de
prélever eux-mêmes dans leur cabinet
pendant leur tournée
ce qui fait gagner du temps de
prélèvements au laboratoire et or ce
moment là on a plus de 110 personnes
pour prélever à changera complètement la
donne mais pour ça il faut que le
gouvernement a choisi de donner une main
situation à faire ce genre de choses
alors pour se faire dépister un plus
facilement
la présidente de la région de votre
région a déployé des des camions de
dépistage itinérant à tourcoing dans le
nord vous êtes exactement les dépistages
sont aussi effectuées en masse est une
bonne chose
j'imagine le dépistage de masse
moi j'en ai toujours très peur parce que
j'ai un film rappelle les vaccinaux de
rôle de madame bachelot et pour rappel
l'échec de la vaccination soit il et
h1n1 est essentiellement due au fait
qu'on ait fait que l'agrément des
vaccinés au doigt et non dans les
cabinets des fous donc moi j'incite tous
mes collègues et elle a bien réfléchi à
cette partie là sur hong kong en main
même le fait de dépister dans nos
cabinets dans la foulée du diagnostic
clairement on va se retrouver avec une
levée de boucliers à un moment ou un
autre entre les tests parce qu'urs à la
structure de la confiance qu'il faut il
faut que mettre un numéro se mettre à
tester
c'est une évidence aussi bien politiques
que techniques
alors à paris en ile de france mais
aussi dans les bouches du rhône dans le
var dans le vaucluse des régions sont
actuellement vigilance est levée
est-ce que les vacances sont fait un peu
oublier les gestes barrière je sais pas
ce qu'ils ont fait oublier gestes
barrières mais fait sûr que les vacances
et puis attendu de tout le monde et que
plus personne n'avait envie d'entendre
parler de cette épidémie et on a entendu
de lait toutes les théories possibles et
inimaginables de déni de la maladie
atteignent épidémie qui se propage et
qui revient et dont l'immunité ne mets
pas ça n'est pas longue et donc très des
très logiquement tant qu'on n'aura pas
de vaccin tels que le vaccin c'est pas
si facile plus fade à voir avec notre
bourreau nazi aura pas d'accord on
n'aura pas de on n'aura pas de dignité
collective dignité collective famille
merci beaucoup bertrand legrand médecins
généralistes et auteur d'un journal du
journal d'un médecin au temps du
couronne à virus aux éditions l'archipel
merci beaucoup